hey guys I'm just McDonald it is the
17th of robbery and you're joining me
for another week of complaining about
frame rates and resolutions I mean news
it's definitely news so let's get this
resolution stuff out of the way early so
we can all move on with our lives it
turns out there was a pretty damn good
reason why Kajima was more into the ps4
version of metal gear solid ground
zeroes because that's the version
running at 1080p Xbox one on the other
hand will have the game running at 720p
though Konami have said they're working
to have both platforms play the game at
60fps the xbox 360 and ps3 versions will
only run at 30 frames per second and the
native resolution is set to be upscaled
to 720p yes for some reason you want to
compare and contrast the images from
each of the platform's konami is letting
you do that on their site with a
comparison video to come later i do know
at this point that most of you including
me a pretty sick of hearing about all
this stuff so let me know in the
comments if there's anything you like
hearing about less than resolutions and
frame rates if you bought yourself an
xbox one and have had your eye on rise
then tomorrow will be the day to pick it
up since it's due to be massively
discounted Microsoft are experimenting
with its digital pricing and part of
that is by making the game cheaper than
you can pick it up at a used game
retailer as if retailers needed another
thing to worry about between verb 18 and
24 the game will cost you thirty nine
ninety nine in the US and about the same
price comparatively in the UK do you
guys reckon this price is fair and you
into buying games digitally let me know
why are why not in the comments in one
of the coolest gaming things that's
happened in ages the social experiment
known as twitch plays pokemon is still
reading on the way it works is that
anybody with the twitter accounts can
input a valid gameboy commerce through
an intelligently designed emulator and
be part of a collaborative pokemon
red/blue playthrough and it's been as
wrought with as much success as it has
been with a frustrating lack of progress
actually it's been way more that second
one than the first at the time over if
this script service
70,000 people have jumped on and the
stream is just about to hit the five-day
law shockingly the chad has made a bunch
of progress and hasn't just walk
themselves in circles for hours on end
if you want to contribute or check out
the madness head to twitch.tv forward
slash twitch plays Pokemon let me know
if you're a fan of these types of
automated streams and if you reckon
they'll make it to the end of Pokemon
you can drop me off or in the comments
down below or on my Twitter where I'm at
Jess McDonald that's all I've got for
you today but be sure to join me again
tomorrow for some more news or you can
check out my newest episode of the gist
where I embarrass myself on the Internet
I'll see you soon